[Música]
sí
[Aplausos]
imagínate te haces una radiografía de
tórax y te diagnostican un cáncer de
pulmón
la fiabilidad de la prueba es del 95%
que haces te preocupas
bueno pues lo importante para
preocuparte no es como de fiable sea la
prueba sino como de rara es tu
enfermedad en este caso la probabilidad
de un falso positivo es del 50%
esto solo es un ejemplo de cómo la
ciencia impregna a nuestras vidas a
todos los niveles
solía decir que hemos creado una
civilización en la que la mayor parte de
los aspectos esenciales dependen
profundamente de la ciencia y la
tecnología y el mismo que las hemos
apañado para que casi nadie sepa de
ciencia y tecnología 3-d un tiempo pero
tarde o temprano esta mezcla de
ignorancia y poder nos va a estallar en
la cara la ciencia nos ayuda a tomar
decisiones con la mejor información por
eso nosotros pensamos que es importante
acercar de esta ciencia a la gente de la
calle
y de verdad es necesario acercar la
ciencia desde la calle pues hay muchas
maneras de informarse pues sí pero
cuidado que no todas valen
audición apareció publicada en la
sección de edificación científica del
diario deportivo 'as'
i
nos produce si no sois capaces del
veneno que pone porque si tenéis más de
20 años probablemente aquí siempre
ocurriría si el sol se apagará de
repente y la cuestión es que bueno pues
el sol no se va a pagar de repente por
si alguno tiene dudas porque el sol no
tiene un interruptor lo que ocurre es
que si el sol en algún momento se acaba
el combustible pues para cuando eso
ocurra la vida en la tierra se habrá
extinguido muchos millones de años atrás
e incluso la propia tierra en sí lo más
preocupante de todas maneras es lo que
viene a continuación cuando afirman que
el primer cambio que notaríamos sería la
ausencia de luz aunque tendríamos la luz
de la luna pero no a todas las horas
supongo que sólo de noche ni en todo
y nosotros nos preguntamos si quizá la
luna que tiene en mente la autora del
artículo no es esta no es el satélite
que refleja la luz del sol
y va por bluetooth
bueno y aquí en naviego aragón vamos
paseando por la calle san joaquín
doblamos la esquina y nos encontramos
con la calle paralela de san joaquín que
es ser profesor de matemáticas y aquí
que nos pilla cerca es duro duro
o en la rioja hay una media de 142 bares
por persona según un estudio
qué digo yo qué bien bueno a ver ana qué
es lo que está pasando aquí lo que dice
la neuropsicología al respecto sobre lo
que nos encontramos lo que ocurre
nuestro cerebro cuando se encontraba con
un número en un texto escrito
los ponteses a vital inferior porque es
una representación del sentido
cuantitativo de los números
y qué bien
con la neuropsicología pero yo tengo una
teoría un poco más cuñada al respecto
vais a perdonar pero a mí me da la
impresión de que lo que ocurre en
nuestro cerebro cuando nos encontramos
con un número en un texto escrito es
algo así nos interesa que estamos otra
cosa que desconectamos y para analizar
noticias como las que hemos visto hasta
ahora no es especialmente importante lo
grave viene cuando los ciudadanos
hacemos dejación de responsabilidades y
nos desentendemos de la ciencia a la
hora de tomar otras decisiones que si
pueden tener una trascendencia más seria
en nuestras vidas
esta noticia es reciente una familia
francesa sin vacunar se va de vacaciones
a costa rica introduce el sarampión en
este país una familia francesa sin
vacunar cómo es posible si la vacuna es
gratis en francia bueno digo francia
pero podría decir españa o cualquier
otro país del primer mundo y es que el
movimiento anti vacunas está creciendo
este movimiento experimentó un gran auge
a finales de los años 90 cuando un
médico británico andrew wakefield
publicó un estudio fraudulento donde
establecía una causalidad entre la
vacuna triple vírica
y el desarrollo del trastorno del
espectro autista para este estudio uso
datos falsos y además tenía intereses
económicos personales
la revista retiró el artículo y el
colegio médico británico y lo expulsó
por mala praxis y deshonestidad desde
entonces ningún otro estudio médico
científico serio ha conseguido probar
esta relación pero el movimiento anti
vacuna sigue creciendo
claro algunos políticos o famosos con
muchas voces en las redes sociales
siguen haciendo eco de este artículo y
la comunidad científica no se oye tanto
sin embargo los científicos lo tienen
claro
las vacunas funcionan
el niño a que se refiere esta noticia
podría haberse curado con un simple
antibiótico pero su familia mal
aconsejada decidió tratar la economía
para tía cuando ingresó en coma de un
hospital ya no se pudo hacer nada por él
es cierto en muchas enfermedades es
fundamental en la detección temprana y
qué determina de manera crucial las
posibilidades de recuperación porque la
medicina es imperfecta es verdad tiene
efectos secundarios a veces causa
muertes pero también es cierto que ha
contribuido a prolongar y mejorar
nuestras vidas en españa por ejemplo
hemos pasado de una esperanza de vida de
34 años en 1900 a 80 en 2015 ya nada
pero no medidas que las farmacéuticas no
se lucran a costa de nuestras
enfermedades claro y las petroleras y
las hidroeléctricas a costa de nuestra
necesidad de energía y las telefónicas a
costa de nuestra necesidad de
comunicación pero a nadie se le ocurre
proponer que abandonemos los móviles y
empecemos a comunicarnos mediante el
silbo gomero bueno y digo el silbo
gomero que al menos este método de
comunicación ha demostrado eficacia en
el contexto en el que se utiliza y estas
pseudo terapias no sería equivalente a
proponer que dejaremos los móviles y
empezáramos a comunicarnos pues qué sé
yo por telepatía por ejemplo lo que de
verdad debería preocuparnos como
sociedad es que alguien se lucre a costa
de nuestra ignorancia de nuestra
ignorancia científica quiero decir pues
curioso porque es justamente la gente
con mayor nivel educativo la que cree
más que la media en este tipo
cierto pero es que el conocimiento no es
binario no es algo que se tiene o no se
tiene una persona con un nivel alto de
estudios puede ir bastante justita en
temas de ciencia pero bueno esto de la
homeopatía así que es a ver voy a
resumir mucho la miopatía básicamente
consiste en diluir a escalas cósmicas
una sustancia de eficacia no demostrada
y después pulverizar las sobre bolitas
de sacarosa o lactosa es decir
químicamente es 100%
la pseudo terapias matan y la homeopatía
es azúcar mojado
esta niña se llama greta y desde este
verano todos los viernes va al
parlamento sueco porque dice que le
estamos dejando sin futuro que dejemos
de discutir y hagamos algo para cambiar
el cambio climático provocado por el ser
humano discutir la comunidad científica
de manera casi unánime sabe que el
cambio climático es antropogénico quizá
existe un 23 por ciento de científicos
que lo niegan pero los medios de
comunicación con la idea de dar voz a
todos a todas las opiniones caen en el
falso principio de la equidad es decir
es como si la junta electoral diera el
mismo tiempo de publicidad gratuita a un
partido que tiene un 2% de
representación que a un partido que
tiene un 25 30 por ciento de
representación para ser justos de verdad
en un programa de una hora los
negacionistas deberían tener 72 73
segundos hay algunos medios de
comunicación como la bbc o wikipedia que
ya han decidido no dar voces a
negacionistas o incluso a gente que
apoye ese pseudo terapias
y bueno claro la comunidad científica lo
tiene claro el cambio climático existe
pero digo yo que a ver en esto estamos
todos de acuerdo yo creo que el bueno la
mayor parte de nosotros sabemos que el
cambio climático está provocado por el
ser humano pues igual que yo que sé que
todos sabemos que la tierra redonda o
más redonda perdona quería decir
esférica ya no está de ser y casa y ya
me salió la matemática achatada por los
polos no no ni achatada ni esférica ni
plana como que plana plana que la tierra
es plana y no te creas que lo piensa
gente que vive aislada en cualquier
sitio no no
de hecho hay un youtuber cuyo nombre no
vamos a decir que tiene casi doscientos
y pico mil seguidores que se permite el
lujo de discutir con pedro duque de tú a
tú con él sobre la tierra sobre esto de
que la tierra es plana y no ocurre
solamente en españa en eeuu solamente el
66 por ciento de gente entre 18 y 24
años está totalmente convencido de que
la tierra es esférica así que bueno y
luego ya que estamos tenemos gente que
piensa que la tierra tiene forma de
donuts hay un modelo para golosos cs o
que la tierra tiene forma de ensaladera
este es el modelo de consenso miran y te
rabo lista mi tierra plan istas ni para
ti ni para mí
esta niña se llama ayotte y tiene 4 años
y vive en india sufre ceguera infantil
como consecuencia de un déficit severo
de vitamina por esta misma razón su
sistema inmunológico está gravemente
comprometido es probable que muera en
menos de un año la organización mundial
de la salud estima que hay 250 millones
de personas que como yo ti padece esta
misma enfermedad fundamentalmente en
asia y áfrica lo más triste es que no
sería caro erradicar esta enfermedad los
suplementos de vitamina que necesita un
niño para todo un año se pueden
conseguir por 25 céntimos lo que es
costosa es la distribución la logística
necesaria para hacer llegar estos
suplementos a áreas remotas rurales es
muy complicada cuesta mucho llegar a
estas zonas y en ocasiones es que no se
llega un grupo internacional de
científicos tuvo una idea brillante lo
que pasaría si pudiéramos hacer llegar
la vitamina una única vez a estos países
puesto que el arroz es la base
alimenticia de países en vías de
desarrollo propuso poner vitamina en el
arroz es lo que conocemos como arroz
dorado y además decidió quitar de
patentes las semillas que fueran a estos
países en vías de desarrollo
claro pero la belleza de esta solución
no radica sólo en su eficacia sino
también en su capacidad dignificadora
porque pone la gestión del problema en
manos de estos países les hace
independientes de la calidad del primer
mundo y de los recortes en ayudas al
desarrollo que decida imponer el
gobierno europeo de turno
la cuestión es que si tenemos una
solución porque no se implementa si
además es viable fácil
en 2016 ciento diez premios nobel
firmaron una carta dirigida a greenpeace
en ella les instaban a que abandonaran
inmediatamente todas las campañas que
tenían en marcha en contra de la roà
dorado esperan estás diciendo ciento
diez premios nobel ciento diez premios
nobel de ciencia además afirmaban que
entre 1 y 2 millones de personas mueren
anualmente debido al déficit de vitamina
se trata de muertes evitables la carta
es demoledora y terminaba diciendo
cuántos millones de personas tienen que
morir en todo el mundo antes de que esto
se considere un crimen contra la
humanidad
la verdad es que entre los científicos
la cosa está muy clara el consenso sobre
la seguridad de los transgénicos es
comparable al que existe en torno a la
existencia del cambio climático pero por
alguna razón esto no se traduce en apoyo
de la población curiosamente las mismas
personas que respetan el criterio de los
científicos que trabajan en asuntos de
clima y que les considera un poco menos
que héroes porque se enfrentan a grandes
corporaciones también opinan que todos
los que trabajan en agricultura
diseñando transgénicos son unos vendidos
a esas mismas grandes empresas o no son
héroes y otros son villanos y eddie te
paga monsanto claro esa es la coletilla
da igual que trabajen para instituciones
públicas que se den los resultados de
sus investigaciones a la sociedad si la
ciencia me lleva la contraria es porque
la ciencia se ha vendido además los
transgénicos son una buena manera de
luchar contra el cambio climático porque
por ejemplo se pueden diseñar para que
necesiten muy poquita agua
bueno pues está claro los transgénicos
son seguros como todos aquellos que se
han manifestado o que han marcado sus
opiniones en estos temas hemos recibido
amenazas e insultos por las redes
sociales podríamos no hacer nada y
quedarnos en casa pero sentimos que
tenemos la capacidad y el deber de dar
un paso adelante y posicionarnos
desde hace unos años vamos por colegios
e institutos centros de mayores hablando
de matemáticas acercando las de manera
divertida por ejemplo aquí estamos en un
skate room de criptografía que hicimos
en un instituto y desde hace unos meses
hemos dado un paso más allá y hemos
decidido llevar la ciencia a los bares
sumándonos a una corriente que ya existe
como paint of science u otras más
grandes somos tres científicas dos de
ellas nosotros y la tercera se llama
angélica benito de la universidad
autónoma de madrid y una vez al mes
llevamos a un científico experto en un
área a que nos hable entre tapas y
ciencia de su campo de interés claro y
por qué porque en un bar pues cuanto
parece bien la rioja
la idea es quitarle a la ciencia ese
aura de frikismo y solemnidad que
habitualmente les rodea quizá los
científicos hemos pecado de vivir un
poco de espaldas a la sociedad pero para
afrontar los retos que tenemos por
delante necesitamos que la sociedad esté
de nuestro lado y para eso hay que
humanizar la ciencia una buena manera de
conseguirlo es traer a un científico
como hacemos nosotros todos los meses
para que hable con pasión de algo de su
campo y cuando eso ocurre creedme que se
nota
[Aplausos]
como veis necesitamos cierta
infraestructura pero contamos con
distintas entidades que nos prestan los
altavoces con amigos que nos ayudan a
hacer las grabaciones a hacer las fotos
todo muy familiar y muy local así
también nos interesa nos apetece que el
tejido social de la zona participe del
proyecto y por eso tenemos unos
colaboradores muy especiales la ong a
lenta
porque es verdad que nosotros no podemos
pagar a nuestros ponentes pero eso no
significa que se vayan con las manos
vacías todos los meses
ellos nos regalan un montón de horas de
trabajo para que nosotros podamos
ofrecer a nuestros conferenciantes una
obra de artesanía única e irrepetible
pues como decía antes juanma ellos dicen
que ayudan a hacer divulgación
científica y estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con ellos
y así es una tarde de tapas y ciencia en
casa valentina
[Música]
bueno como veis lo pasamos fenomenal la
verdad es que el ambiente es muy
distendido muy agradable pero no por eso
la ciencia que se cuenta deja de ser
rigurosa nuestra idea es que cada uno de
los que vienen se vayan con la idea de
voy a buscar información
voy a contrastarla con medios fiables y
voy a pensar por mí mismo porque si no
lo hago yo otros lo harán por mí
no podemos ver la realidad tal y como es
porque nuestra visión del mundo está
sesgada pero podemos confiar en el
método científico para que nos ayude a
dejar atrás prejuicios sesgos e
intereses porque sin ciencia no hay
futuro
[Aplausos]